there's likely no person on earth who's
doing more to dismantle idea segregation
than him the legacy media tried to take
him down with his coveted content he had
doctors on who disagreed with fauci but
the takedown didn't take so now some
mysterious group released a supercut of
joe saying the n-word over a decade or
so probably matching what previous
democrat senators and presidents would
say in the one afternoon
the fact that the montage was released
after spotify stuck with rogan tells you
it's less about the word
and more about canning joe
that was greg gutfeld calling out the
left for refusing to give up their push
to cancel joe rogan
as more artists ditched spotify in
protest of rogan's content now rumble is
offering rogan a 100 million dollar deal
to join its video platform saying quote
we stand with you your guests and your
legion of fans
in desire for real conversation
fox and friends weekend co-host will
kane joins us now will i think this is
the first chance i've had to interview
you on fox and friends oh what i may ask
but we will stick to the topic at hand
for now joe rogan you follow this stuff
you're a podcaster he's for years been
been an intellectually curious guy now
they're trying to cancel them what do
you make of this counteroffer as well
i love the counteroffer pete you and i
have talked about this creating separate
ecosystems parallel ecosystems ones that
honor look
not just conservative values but the
foundational values of western culture
ideas and concepts like free speech i
did talk about this on the latest
episode of the will kane podcast pete
because i don't think this is simply an
attack against those who have concerns
over the long-term ramifications of the
vaccine this is actually a concerted and
i mean concerted a coordinated attack
against someone who committed the
cardinal sin of independent thought
that's what makes joe rogan so important
and were he to move to some place like
rumble why it would be such an
earthquake a game changer pete because
he's unpredictable he represents
independence and we need someone like
that to chart a course that brings an
audience that helps tear down this
really rotten and corrupt not just
political economy but corporate economy
that's now sold out basic fundamentals
of western civilization
absolutely well uh you know i we we love
you at fox and we want you here but
we're if rumble were to offer you 100
million dollars uh would you go
you know in great dan bongino fashion
having learned from the master of
promotion i just want to point out to
the audience i am on rumble as we speak
there you go
you didn't get 100 million i don't think
but you can catch him on rumble smart
man you don't know you don't know you
don't know what that may be for me you
know you know i don't i don't know
you're exactly right i'll have to put it
in the hr inquiry but here's an
interesting part about it
joe rogan's been doing a lot of
apologizing recently uh and and donald
trump
chimed in on this late last night with a
statement i want to get you to react to
it
trump said joe rogan is an interesting
and popular guy but he's got to stop
apologizing to the fake news and radical
left maniacs and lunatics how many ways
can you say you're sorry joe just go
about what you do so well and don't let
them make you look weak and frightened
that's not you and it never will be what
do you make of this advice
okay so one of the things i appreciate
about joe rogan as a listener and i do
listen he is he's earnest i think he
truly wants to be a better person always
learn always evolve and when he
apologizes i generally think that's
coming from a very earnest place not a
place of surrender for example but he
needs to understand this is like and i'm
trying to struggle for the right analogy
here it's like well honestly it's like
being in war and your opponent who look
who's looking to kill you giving you
advice along the way these aren't real
criticisms their criticism of him is not
earnest they don't believe he's a racist
they don't even care about his vaccine
stance they simply want to kill his
independents and one of the lessons we
learned
from donald trump and i think that
remains today is always stay on offense
don't apologize because it's not a fair
game they're not looking to actually
help make you or this world a better
place
and i'll tie this up in the end pete
with i said it's a coordinated attack go
watch and if you haven't pete go check
it out you know the president of
barstool sports confronted three guys
who were looks to be behind this attack
on joe rogan it's a coordinated
political attack the videos coming in
waves at three-day stages
and and and by the way it may not end
they'll move on from here to whatever
sexism misogyny homophobia whatever is
next that they think can get or catch or
cancel
which is why something like rumble is so
tempting the idea that you have an a
real free platform real quick uh david
goggins he's a navy seal
knows joe rogan well put this out on
instagram he wrote what the hidden
message here to me is the fact that
people in positions of power don't
believe we are smart enough to be able
to hear different opinions or capable of
making our own decisions well that's
what joe rogan does so well he brings on
people from both sides lets them talk
puts in his own opinion and he assumes
as a listener you're going to draw your
own conclusions
the difference is he actually believes
in the intelligence and integrity and
trustworthiness of the audience and
those that look to censor think you're a
buffoon hey by the way pete um 75 hard
you know i'm working yeah i was gonna
ask you that was my final question are
you on day six of this insane fitness it
was no day sick you were sick as a dog
this weekend on the show because your
body's rejecting what you're attempting
to do to it now you're six days into
this 75 day fitness challenge are you
still hurting or are you recovering
so so the reason i brought it up is
goggins is one of my inspirations
because he's an absolutely hard
individual um pete no i fell off 75 hard
you saw me you know with the cold sweats
this weekend it turns out i don't know
if i've got the norovirus or what man
but it's in the whole house now i just
want you to know that so that's the
warrior that i am i got a kid upstairs
who's you know hovering over a bowl all
night long
it wasn't the 75 heart that got me my
discipline has not faltered i'm on i'm
going to do it i'm re-upping i'm doing
it we're going to restart the 75 days
i'm doing it with you yeah you're not
you're going to have to ask brian or
steve if he'll do it with you i think
i'm out
nope steve's out too
oh ainsley's in you might have a willing
accomplice
here we go 75 days a lot of things you
don't want to do okay okay yeah i'll
i'll tell you in the comments they're
telling me we need to go all right well
kane you're the man we'll see you this
weekend for you guys take care and check
out his podcast it's fantastic